it's not just members of the media now
it is democrats full on
card carrying they get a laminated card
card carrying
democrats here is dnc committee member
uh
wait is this aaron burnett is that his
name or he's on the aaron burnett show
is his name aaron burnett i'll get back
to you in just a second on that but this
is a dnc committee member he's the chair
of the miami-dade democrat party saying
what biden should or should not do
what's your reason for i mean is that
your reason for not thinking you should
run again or is it just quite simply as
david axelrod said at the end of his
next term he'd be closer to 90 than 80.
you know what what is the reason
it's a host of factors the first being
that the approval rating is not where it
should be at this point
but also more importantly if you look at
the polls with regards to the direction
of the country less than a quarter of
americans think that our country is on
the right track with polls like that
people are going to be looking for a
change candidate they're not going to be
looking to vote for an incumbent with
approval ratings down in the 30s okay to
be clear in case you're confused that
was aaron burnett the host of the cnn
comedy program and steve simonides is
the head of the democrat party here in
miami-dade county and basically he's out
there saying
uh this thing ain't working now let's
flash back all the way to yesterday
remember yesterday it's pretty good day
everything being equal
and aoc
was basically saying she is not going to
support biden right like we played the
clip we're going to play a little bit of
it for you right here
and some of my response i was on newsmax
last night uh recapping it and remember
before i always say they say let's be
clear so you'll see what i did here
but aoc ain't supporting him either and
the thing is bursting forth
president biden he is saying he's going
to run again in 2024 will you support
him
you know if the president chooses uh to
run again in 2024 i mean first of all
i'm focused on winning this majority
right now uh and preserving a majority
this year in 2022 so we'll cross that
bridge when we get to it but um but i
think if if the president has a vision
and that's something certainly we're all
willing to entertain and examine when
the when the time comes
that's not a yes
yeah you know i think we should
endorse when we get to it but i i
believe that the president has been
doing a very good job uh so far and um
you know should he run again i think
that i you know i think it's it's
we'll take a look at it
okay
so no
well let's be clear i mean there is zero
chance that joe biden is running again
and i mean that zero quote me on this
click this thing and send it across the
internet there's no chance
send it across the internet people on
the computer machine the guy is not
running again obviously uh yesterday he
did an event and the press started
asking him questions and look how fast
this old man is when he has to get
moving
yeah we're not gonna ask any questions
i'm not gonna answer anything i'm joe
biden he's fast when he needs to be fast
but what does this all mean what does
this all mean okay you get it biden's no
good the party's turning against him the
media is waking up
well there was an orange man and you may
remember him he was very popular a few
years ago
then the internet decided to kick him
off
but he might come back
back in the state where presidential
campaigns are born former president
trump rallying supporters and hinting at
a 2024 bid back to make america great
again
dash
slash comma again
make america great again again i don't
know
that's him at his best that's him at his
best when he's being silly and funny and
the whole thing what do the democrats
think about him coming back
do not come
do not come
i'm gonna come
[Applause]
[Music]
that's some good work guys